Texas Republican senator Ted Cruz has
now eliminated any doubt whatsoever that
remained that yes he is a completely
disgusting and immoral human being we
are going to look at a couple of
examples here uh in the first couple
segments of the show at the hypocritical
and disgusting reactions from multiple
Republicans to the latest news that Mike
Pence also had classified documents at
his home now later in the program and
maybe tomorrow even we're going to look
at the rise of immediate conspiracy
theories surrounding the classified
document story involving Joe Biden and
Mike Pence but for now let's look at the
pretzels that some of these Republicans
are twisting themselves into and
sometimes very brazenly Ted Cruz
appeared on television with Larry Kudlow
Larry Kudlow I guess after working for
Trump he got a show back now on Fox
Business and as you can see if you if
you're watching Kudlow just looks like
he really enjoys himself when he hosts
these shows doesn't he and Ted Cruz
started talking about oh well the the
FBI needs to investigate not only Joe
Biden but hunter Biden because of
everything that's going on and Larry
Kudlow to his credit
plays a sort of soft Devil's Advocate
and says well I don't know I mean you
know Pence also had documents there and
Ted Cruz I don't know don't worry about
that we know where those documents came
from do we take a listen to this then
this shifts from a political problem to
a very serious problem of criminal
liability and and Major Crimes and so
the API needs to search the University
of Delaware archives and they need to
search Hunter Biden's home and business
address
um just as an addendum to this the news
came out today I'm sure you saw it that
former vice president Mike Pence a
friend of both of ours he's found some
classified documents it turns out that a
friend of both of ours is a big factor
here I think in his home in Indiana not
in his office uh what do you make of
that is this different from the Biden
story does this just like I know this is
totally meaningless Senator but like
just so I can say I put the question on
the record there's no similarity is
there complicate the story are we going
to continue the bull market and special
councils I'd rather have a bull market
in stocks than in special councils how
do you see at Santa Cruz
Oh look The the Mike Pence story it's
still early uh you know Mike Pence and
as you noted he is a good friend he's a
good man he's explained where these came
from what his office has put out is is
that in packing up the vice presidential
offices that that there were a couple of
papers that were classified that were
inadvertently a couple inadvertently
with non-classified materials that was a
mistake but there's no reason uh to
think it was anything but inadvertent
there is no reason to think that the
Biden stuff was anything but inadvertent
listen it's not partisan for me it's not
even partisan as some of our our friends
across the the pond like to say there
are right now three situations we know
about Trump Biden and Pence I have no
reason to believe that the Biden one is
anything but inadvertent if the facts
change I will revise my opinion I have
no reason to think that the Pence
situation is anything but inadvertent
the facts change I will revise my
opinion I have every reason to think
that the Trump situation is deliberate
given the dozens of different data
points and and reports about Trump
directed people to do this once the FBI
a national archives became interested in
the documents they're on video moving
the documents around rather than simply
packing them up to be turned back over
to the National Archives the fact that
Trump pushed his lawyers to lie and say
we gave you back what we have even
though Trump knew that they hadn't it's
piece of evidence upon piece of evidence
these are three situations two seem
benign one seems deliberately criminal
that is very very different from what
Joe Biden has done Joe Biden has given
zero explanation as to how these
classified documents got there and in
particular
he has given no explanation as to how he
has documents from his time in the
Senate listen yeah so um as as many of
you of course know the Republican party
and people like Ted Cruz are numb to
hypocrisy it's astonishing hypocrisy
it's it's mind-blowing and they are
completely numb or immune to it there is
no political punishment for it in fact
often they are rewarded for maintaining
the party line the way that Ted Cruz is
doing and at the end of the day what the
hell do you expect from a guy who had
his wife called ugly by Donald Trump and
then turned around and supported Trump
and talked about how great how great
Trump is now there's another side to
this okay maybe we see it as hypocrisy
but they don't what I mean by that is
they might see it as we aren't
Hypocrites we are good and Democrats are
bad we deserve power Democrats don't we
are above reproach even for the same
things that we criticize democrats for
doing doing and that's it right it could
be a means justify the end sort of thing
and that they fundamentally deserve
different treatment and different
considerations even for the same things
when applied to Democrats that's a
possibility
the other is they're just Hypocrites and
brazenly so and why would they stop
being Hypocrites given that they are
never punished for it so that's Ted Cruz
let's now go to another example of this
you might remember that a few years ago
uh the show got hacked and many
thousands of dollars were stolen we
never got it back it's a terrible
feeling it can happen to anyone but a
couple of years ago we got Aura which
really gives us significantly more peace
of mind and our sponsor Aura is the app
that protects you from scammers by
alerting you anytime your info like
email passwords social security number
are found in data breaches or also
automatically requests removal of your
info from search engines and it can
reduce spam calls Aura alerts you
quickly about suspicious credit
inquiries like if someone tries to take
a loan out in your name and or as
password manager makes it easy to keep
your account secure to begin with aura
also has parental controls for your kids
devices you can restrict apps or manage
screen time set Focus time make sure
they're doing homework instead of
binging on YouTube you can try Aura free
for 14 days at aura.com Pacman use the
free trial to see if your email password
are already out there you may be
surprised the link is down below